CHANGE.
SERENAAMS' RENE STUBBS, HER REA
G WIN. A JGE
IN WESPACH, IDA,
ITS FILING, ITS PAGUMENT IN FAV.
THE LAWYERS EVERAL PNTS
RESORING DOE
NOT DENY TT
CLFIPORTEDUS
THE INTHIS CRIMINAS D DISCOVERY
ANTICIPATED GIVEN THE VE RE REC.
SIMPLY P T WOULD
CONTAIN E INFORMATION
SHOULDER ASE
E NO GG
FORMER SPECIGE
AT THE FBI'S OFFICE IN NK D VIC
ANTI-DAGUE. ABOUT THA ANYONEE OD
BEG -A-LAGO  T
SLIDING  AND IT'SOMETHTHERH
WARRANT OROPERATION, BUT AT
POIOWAY THESED
DOCUMENTHAT HERE
DENIED HAVING, BUT NOW IT'
HIS NCORD "DECSS
NOT MEP ANYWHERE IN IN
L TEAMT ASEAGUE DOCUMENT H
ARGUME WMASTER.AHA
INMSOU WERE JUST LKAB INADVERTE
DENIED HISOCIAL MEDIA
DO POSTE
WERE IN  AFFIDAVIT RELEASED
ENTSWEN TH WEE AS IF TT'S  FBI
HOME
F CARTON
ONRPET.M, ME.RY. HAVEP
S PRESENDUID TTSK THEM OUT OONSD
WISW G THAT HE HAD THES
TS RIGHT
THERE?
NYELL YOU LESS
SPE
WAIT UNT IS A QUESTION
ASD .
BUT IN THIS CASE EVEION THCONTTR
AINER IN THI
OF HUNDREDST N  FSEARCH THESE O
TH IS
SIMPLY MAD SHOW THATE CONTAINER
PICTURT,ERWAS INONIN'MNG
THIS
ASSIEVIDENTIPHOTO,UTTHE FORMERI
ADMITT TY,D COME FROM A CONTAIN
REDE CERTAINLY LEGLY OBLEMATIC.
>> ANO ALAST NIGHTHEOF
AGAIN, I THINK SHE W TALKING
ABOUT THOTO ANWETHE FLOOR SUGGEL
NEVER LOOK LIKE THAT UNDER
>> I HAVE BEEN DOWN 'M FEN
NEVER SEEN
I  NEN TATY HIFI
LOOKS, A FRETLER S ISSUE.
HEASUESTS FREQUENT THEREWHAT DO
BU DOING RIGHTTHE  NOW
THONY WEREIG ASSUME FROMT LYS NT
OFFICE. HAVE TO ASSUME THATHAT
INFORMATN  D
TS NOW.
HANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOREIOVERNIGHT WA